Кордон між Литвою та Росією. Тут, у містечку Віштинець минуло все життя Марійони Шукаускіен.
82 роки вона мешкає на кордоні з Калінінградською областю.
Раніше це був кордон зі Східною Прусією, потім з Радянським Союзом.
Колись литовці часто ходили по той бік кордону. Зараз таке - неможливо.
Ні, нині навіть якщо захочемо, переходити не можна. У цій порі року на тій стороні
багато грибів. Раніше ми їх збирали і приносили додому.
Проте часи приязних сусідських відносин – в далекому минулому.
Наприклад, цієї осені Росія планує масштабні військові навчання.
Ми вже звикли до розповідей про небезпеку з боку Росії. Нехай вони спокійно проводять
свої маневри. Ми нічого не можемо з цим вдіяти. Інколи солдати тренуються - це їхня робота.
Після початку війни на Сході України литовська влада вирішила збудувати огорожу на кордоні,
щоб показати великому сусіду, де закінчується його територія. Разом з одним з одним з депутатів
парламенту Литви ми вирушаємо на місце будівельних робіт. Загалом на кордоні встановили
12 тисяч металевих стовпчиків для паркану. Але поки – це все, що є.
Стовпчики могли б бути вищими. Я вже бачив набагато вищі – наприклад, в Угорщині.
Краще було б до 3-4 метрів заввишки.
Найбільше Лауріанас Касіунас боїться, що одного дня Росія надішле через кордон солдатів -
так званих "зелених чоловічків", як це було в українському Криму.
Росія може знову взяти нашу країну під контроль. Російські правителі не знають,
де пролягає даржавний кордон. Це російська історична ділема.
Наприкінці нашої довгої подорожі вздовж кордону ми зустріли місцевого фермера. Після виснажливої
роботи Лаймонас відпочиває на березі річки, через яку проходить кордон між Росією і Литвою.
Іноді росіяни проводять маневри і на тому боці вибухають бомби.  Два роки тому
були такі сильні вибухи, що у нас шибки з вікон мало не повилітали.
Огорожа на кордоні Лаймонаса не заспокоює. Він каже – паркан від вторгнення все-одно не врятує.
І про всяк випадок запливає тільки до середини річки - далі вже починається територія сусідів.